la grande bretagne est célèbre les 80
100 d'eads elizabeth 2 comme le veut la
tradition la reine a assisté au
rassemblement des couleurs trooping the
colour cette parade militaire où lui
sont présentées les drapeaux des
régiments de l'armée britannique devant
des dizaines de milliers de sujets de sa
majesté se tenait un parfum écologistes
entourer ces commémorations sur place
maryse burgot et dominique mara telle
une reine souriante et enthousiaste un
défilé aérien exceptionnel au dessus de
londres et la famille royale quasiment
au grand complet
il fallait bien cela pour fêter les 80
ans d'elizabeth ii
elle est née un 21 avril mais c'est
traditionnellement en juin que les
britanniques fête l'anniversaire de leur
souverain en cinquante deux déjà lors de
sa première année de règne
elisabeth présidait cette cérémonie
militaire à l'époque elle le faisait à
cheval
aujourd'hui c'est en calèche aux côtés
de son mari le prince philip qu'elle
remonte le célèbre mall l'avenue qui
mène à buckingham
une journée très consensuel avec
pourtant cette année un petit couac la
une de ce grand quotidien
est-il bien nécessaire demande ce
journal d'exterminer des ours du canada
pour fabriquer ces fameuses toque en
fourrure de la garde royale à raison
d'un ours par chapeau même les fans
d'élise avec deux ne comprennent pas
j'ai observé patients moi je croyais que
c'était du nez long sinon je ne serais
jamais venu ici à côté une réalité
dénoncée par plusieurs groupes de
défense des animaux cela manifestaient
en mai dernier à londres dans le plus
simple appareil pour l'heure défendre
les militaires explique que des toc
enfin meetic deviendrait beaucoup trop
lourde en cas de pluie la reine n'a
jamais pris publiquement position sur
cette affaire de chapeau ce n'est pas à
80 ans qu'elle va abandonner son
légendaire sens de la réserve
on ne sait donc pas du tout ce qu'elle
pense de cette polémique